bonsoir ian brossât merci beaucoup avec
nous sur rt france alors ça a duré très
longtemps deux heures d'exposé deux
heures parfois un peu complexe
d'ailleurs sur ce que l'on sait ce que
l'on ne sait pas l'état des stocks
l'état de la menace les défis à relever
qu'en avez vous retenu de ces deux
heures d'exposé de d'edouard philippe et
et son ministre de la santé
j'ai trouvé que c'était une conférence
de presse enfin une allocution en
réalité qui était à la fois très longue
et finalement assez incomplète parce que
les français se posent aujourd'hui
beaucoup de questions beaucoup de
questions sur l'état de leur système de
santé beaucoup de questions sur ce à
quoi le déconfinement ressemblera et sur
ces deux questions là on n'a pas
véritablement de réponse et le sentiment
qu'on a c'est que en matière de
déconfinement il y a pour l'instant une
date qui a été fixée par le président de
la république mais il n'y a pas de plan
il n'y a pas de plan de déconfinement et
le premier ministre reconnaît d'ailleurs
lui même qu'il n'a pas de réponse à
cette question là or c'est précisément
la question principale que les français
se posent aujourd'hui
oui d'autant qu'il l'a avoué il n'y a
toujours pas suffisamment de matériel de
protection pour le personnel soignant
est ce que c'est parce que justement on
ne sait pas encore comment est ce qu'on
va pouvoir protéger au niveau des
masques les français notamment que ceux
des confinement en tout cas ce plan se
fait attendre selon vous mais bien
évidemment c'est parce que nous n'avons
pas de masque en nombre suffisant parce
que nous n'avons pas de test en nombre
suffisant qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
préciser les conditions du déconfinement
et puis par ailleurs quand le premier
ministre nous dit avec une forme d'auto
satisfaction qu'il est très heureux que
la france produisent non plus 4 millions
de masques par semaine mais 8 millions
de masques par semaine grâce aux grands
efforts réalisés par le gouvernement
il ya comme un décalage c'est peut-être
qu'au maroc on produit 5 millions de
masques par jour qu'en allemagne on a un
objectif de production de 50 millions de
masques par semaine et donc la france
est très très très loin de tout ça parce
que depuis des années nous avons
affaibli nos capacités productives nous
n'avons plus vérité
ble ment d'état qui se mobilisent pour
défendre son industrie et c'est ce que
nous payons aujourd'hui et je pense
qu'on aurait besoin que le gouvernement
fasse dans ce domaine une vraie auto
critique et qu'on se donne les moyens de
reconstruire nos capacités productives
en france ouais c'est ce qu'a évoqué
d'ailleurs ollier verront faire revenir
justement toutes ces entreprises
primordial les laboratoires toutes les
entreprises qui y participent à la
sécurité sanitaire des français les
faire revenir en france à apprendre du
temps ça aussi vous pensez
ça va prendre du temps mais surtout il
faudrait qu'on ait l'assurance que le
gouvernement est prêt à le faire aux
recettes en contradiction totale avec la
politique qui a été menée dans notre
pays depuis des années maintenant et
singulièrement depuis qu emmanuel macron
et président de la république nous
payons une logique qui a consisté à
laisser notre industrie se délocaliser
et à perdre une forme de notre de notre
souveraineté et donc il y a besoin d'une
vraie rupture
en tout cas pour ce qui nous concerne au
parti communiste nous l'appelons de nos
voeux et je ne pense pas véritablement
qu'on puisse compter sur ce gouvernement
là pour engager cette rupture
ou alors ce serait un vrai changement
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu depuis deux
ans maintenant il ya une annonce
concrète ce soir et demain le
l'autorisation des visites dans les
ehpad
c'est essentiel évidemment on imagine
pour la psychologie l'équilibré
psychologique des personnes qui
souffrent actuellement dans ces
établissements nouvelle oui c'est une
bonne chose parce qu'on en était arrivé
à une situation totalement inhumaines ou
des personnes âgées se retrouver seul en
ehpad sans que leurs familles et la
possibilité d'aller leur rendre visite
cela dit il y à des questions qui
restent entières premier ministre a dit
on a fait 50 mille tests dans les ehpad
on a besoin d'en faire bien davantage
parce qu'on sait que les soignants dans
les ehpad les personnels dans les ehpad
particulièrement explorer exposés oraux
coville est donc on a besoin
d'une montée en puissance des tests et
c'est aussi ce qui permettra que la
situation s'améliore dans les ehpad
parce que franchement s'il ya bien
quelque chose qui devrait faire honte à
notre pays aujourd'hui c'est la
situation de nos maisons de retraite
ian brossât vous êtes adjoint à la
mairie de paris anne hidalgo a annoncé
qu'il y aura des mavs pour les parisiens
d'ici à la fin du mois d'avril
vous confirmez oui il y aura cinq cent
mille masques qui seront disponibles à
la fin du mois d'avril en priorité pour
les personnes les plus fragiles pour les
personnes âgées et dc le déconfinement
donc d'ici la mi mai il y aura un masque
pour chaque parisien comme la maire de
paris s'y était engagé on est d'ailleurs
dans une situation au delà de paris où
les collectivités locales font beaucoup
et où les collectivités locales d'une
certaine manière se substitue à l'état
c'est parce que l'état n'est pas capable
de le faire que les collectivités
locales sont amenés à mettre en place
des politiques qui visent à protéger
leurs populations
c'est ce que nous faisons à paris mais
c'est ce que d'autres maires d'autres
couleurs politiques d'ailleurs font sur
leur territoire et voir filer pas dit
qu'il fallait assurer la continuité de
la nation c'est la priorité de ceux des
confinement à travers évidemment la
reprise du travail et la réouverture des
écoles de sachs qui l'a détaillé pour
préserver notamment pour essayer de
réfléchir à des mesures pour préserver
la sécurité des français
mais en tout cas à rétablir aussi la
capacité d'accueil dans les hôpitaux
voilà à peu près la stratégie qui va
être mise en oeuvre le travail la remise
au travail à l'école à partir du 11 mai
vous y croyez mais à quel prix
la reprise du travail bien sûr
simplement la reprise du travail dans
des conditions qui évite aux salariés de
courir des risques sanitaires et de la
même manière d'ailleurs à l'école le
premier ministre nous dit il y aura un
certain nombre d'élèves on sait pas bien
lesquels d'ailleurs qui reprendront le
chemin de l'école à partir du 11 mai
mais il n'ya au jour
lui aucune espèce de précision sur les
conditions dans lesquelles l'école
pourra reprendre et donc il y a encore
après cette conférence de presse
beaucoup de questions bien sûr que la
vie doit reprendre après le 11 mai mais
le rôle de l'état le rôle de n'importe
quel état c'est de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse reprendre la vie si ce n'est
normal du moins une vie qui ressemble un
peu plus à la vie de tous les jours mais
dans des conditions sanitaires qui soit
celle d'un grand pays comme la france
c'est je crois le défi auquel nous
sommes confrontés aujourd'hui et les
questions auxquelles il faudra répondre
dans les jours qui viennent parce que
pour l'instant sur ces questions là on
n'a pas véritablement de réponse aucune
aucune réponse on a entendu le le chef
du gouvernement dira on imagine des
classes réduites de moitié on imagine
des élèves qui viendraient une semaine
sur deux voilà donc toutes les
hypothèses sont sur la table et on ne
sait toujours pas qui seraient concernés
les élèves
on le sait qu'ils ont des difficultés
scolaires dans certaines zones peut-être
rentrer avant d'autres vous pensez que
c'est la bonne méthode ce serait en tout
cas la bonne méthode
moi je pense que l'école et c'est son
principe même elle doit s'adresser à
l'ensemble des élèves quel que soit le
lieu dans lequel ils vivent quelles que
soient les origines sociales de leurs
parents est ce qui fait la richesse de
l'école c'est précisément le brassage
social
et c'est précisément ce pour l'instant
vers quoi on se dirige pas puisqu'on
nous dit que ce sont uniquement les
enfants les plus fragiles ou ceux des
milieux les plus modestes qui
reprendront le chemin de l'école demain
moi je pense surtout qu'on aurait besoin
que le gouvernement mette en place les
mesures nécessaires les masques les
tests qui permettent que tout le monde
puisse revenir à l'école simplement
comme il n'ya pas de masse pas de test
en nombre suffisant ça ne sera pas
possible le 11 mai prochain donc tous a
conduit le gouvernement à une forme
d'improvisation de flou tout ça reste
très nébuleux et c'est ce qui pose je
crois problèmes aux trois pistes
évoquées par edouard philippe maintenir
le télétravail
on est sur une autre forme de vie là oui
enfin quand on parle du télétravail
on parle quand même d'une classe sociale
qui n'est pas l'ensemble des classes
sociales ce qui télétravaillent ce son
est tant mieux pour eux d'ailleurs
alors ça leur convient ce sont pour
l'essentiel les cadres mais aujourd'hui
il y a malheureusement des salariés qui
continuent à travailler eux dans des
conditions qui parfois ne sont pas
particulièrement sûr je pense au monde
du travail aux ouvriers aux employés qui
parfois continuer à bosser à l'usiné
pour ce qui concerne les ouvriers dans
des conditions très difficiles
quand on voit aussi ce qui s'est passé
avec amazon et le fait que la justice
ait été contrainte d'intervenir
on voit qu'on a des salariés qui sont
aujourd'hui très très exposé et donc ce
que je dis c'est qu'il faut faire
attention à une espèce de deux poids
deux mesures où on aurait des catégories
supérieures qui elle serait protégé et
des catégories plus modestes ouvriers
employés qui elles seraient exposées aux
risques sans que leur santé ne soient
protégés dernière question ian brossât
le 28 avril prochain à l'assemblée
nationale il y aura un débat pour savoir
si on met en place ces fameuses
applications pour traquer les personnes
qui seraient susceptibles d'être
contaminés par corona virus qu'en pensez
vous moi je n'y suis pas favorable et je
pense qu'on ne doit pas mettre le doigt
dans un engrenage comme celui là qui
serait une atteinte à nos libertés sans
savoir d'ailleurs de quelle manière
serait ensuite utilisé ces données
donc bien sûr nous devons veiller à
notre santé bien sûr nous devons mettre
en place tous les moyens de la protéger
mais nous ne devons pas profiter de ce
moment d'une certaine manière pour
remettre en cause un certain nombre de
libertés de libertés fondamentales merci
beaucoup ian brossât a répondu à nos
questions sur arte france